CVS has been very good to us and they go
way out of their way to keep us happy
we've been here you know I think we're
starting our sixth season with TBS soon
and they have been so nice they always
think of new ways to take care of other
fantastic yeah I mentioned this before
they recently went a step further they
started to provide Andy and myself with
in show waiter service it's amazing like
every other show I've worked on every
other you know thing I've ever worked on
we'd go to the commissary you get your
food now they said no Conan and Andy
we at TBS wants you guys to have your
own weight our own waiter right here
they give an in cash they give us these
executive direct restaurant service
menus with TBS on them we can get
anything we want let's bring out our in
show waiter and Ray is I'm a little
hungry let's get him in there you go
there what can I get for you guys Andy
once you go ahead
all right well first I think I'm gonna
start with a cocktail let's do a
Manhattan let's use the Templeton rye oh
and for the vermouth let's use Karpin
are carpa no antica and you know I
really like lemon bitter so you have
lemon bitters from fee brothers that
would be great and also we'll split a
bottle of topo Chico mineral water with
both lemons and limes did you get all
that I did yes you don't want to write
any of this down
not necessary go ahead okay Wow all
right then I'll have the foie gras
tortelloni as my appetizer and I'll have
the Santa Barbara's brought our spot
prawn with the tomato and bronze fennel
as an additional small plate Tony you
want to split the ducked the Liberty
firm duck breast yeah yeah yeah but
Craig instead of the beets that come
with that could you substitute in the
pea tendrils that I see come with the
rack of lamb the pea tendrils of course
I can
just to be safe cuz it's getting a
little complicated you want to write
into that down no a good waiter doesn't
have to do that that's pretty incredible
alright oh and uh let's get a red wine
let's get this dire burg Syrah from the
Santa Maria Valley
okay sure and for your meal Conan okay
I'll start off with the soft-shell crab
with tomatoes scallion creme fraiche and
chorizo vinaigrette
then the halibut sweet corn pudding
spring onions pancetta instead of the
roasted apricots if you could substitute
in the blood orange okay
would you would you please write that
down I I don't need to would you like a
drink to start gonna okay this is a
little unusual I'd like something called
a pistachio mule would you which is what
you're gonna want to write this down
okay so remember just what's in a
pistachio okay it's something I made up
it's two ounces of pistachio gel infused
vodka 0.75 ounces of fresh lime juice
one ounce simple syrup and point five
ounces of fresh ginger juice and just a
splash of ginger beer at the end and
could pour it slowly over the ice for
like 40 seconds got it okay I'm sorry do
you want to repeat that back to me
please so I don't I want to get these
orders in guys I'll be right back with
the food at Drake he's amazing
I didn't get any of that god this is my
only option this is what I gotta do
their pens maybe you should write it
down
hey Eli
he's dead we'll take a break